[Musique]
lens a débuté très tôt c'est un gars
bourré talent il était du genre à
enfourcher son vélo avancé aussi vite
qu'il le pouvait
c'est un athlète incroyable doué d'une
force intérieure absolument fantastique
je refuser d'admettre cette fatalité
j'avais 25 ans j'étais l'un des
meilleurs de ma catégorie et par
conséquent comment pouvait attraper un
cancer je crois qu'il nous renvoie à
notre propre mortalité
il nous montre aussi qu'ils profitent
chaque jour un peu plus de sa vie
attrapez un cancer le survivre jusqu à
en réchapper pour ensuite gagner
l'événement sportif le plus difficile au
monde c'est quelque chose que personne
n'avait jamais réussi à faire et qu'on
ne refera plus
[Musique]
à son retour aux états unis après sa
victoire du tour de france 1999
le cycliste lance armstrong est
accueilli en véritable héros
jusque là peu d'américains se sont
intéressés à ce sport mais non seulement
landes se vient de remporter la
compétition la plus difficile au monde
il a également triomphé d'un cancer 1971
alors que l'amérique se bat au vietnam
et affrontent sur son territoire de
nombreux mouvements contestataires à
dallas une jeune femme de 17 ans linda
monnaie vis avec angoisse sa grossesse
balancer entre ses parents divorcés elle
n'a personne sur qui se reposait et bien
qu'elle ne se sont pas vraiment proche
de son camarade de classe et digg
anderson père du futur enfant elle
parvient néanmoins à le convaincre que
leur mariage reste la meilleure solution
pour leur fils le 18 septembre 1971
mais le petit lens
je vous assure c'était le plus gros
nouveau-né de toute la nurserie et
l'instant où il est né est resté comme
le moment le plus heureux de ma vie
peu après la naissance de lens est dit
et linda divorce obtenant la garde de
son fils linda parvient à les lever en
occupant successivement plusieurs jobs
son gamin on la voyait aussi bien
encaisser les clients chez kruger
kabylie en serveuse au kentucky fried
chicken ducroo un même travaillant à
mi-temps à la poste en 1974 alors que
lens est âgé de 2 ans linda épouse un
vrp du nom de terry amstrong
celui ci adopte officiellement son beau
fils et lui donne son nom
lens vit difficilement l'adoption a vécu
douloureusement le fait que son père
naturel et signer un désaveu de
paternité pour lui ce père était plus un
à ces mines à tort qu'autre chose et je
dirais qu'il n'occupe pas plus de
présence que ça mais lens n'a pas
vraiment d'affinités avec son beau père
un homme très autoritaire console vrais
parents restent sa mère linda je pense
que lens a grandi avec le sentiment
permanent d'être un orphelin de père au
point sans doute que ce sujet le mettez
sur la défensive il est resté très
proche de sa mère dont il est prouvé une
affection telle qu'elle lui permettait
de surmonter sa douleur
bien que l'argent leur manque linda
parvient à économiser suffisamment pour
offrir à son fils un vélo tout terrain à
son septième anniversaire c'était une
bicyclette de course bmx
si je me souviens bien il m'a écoutée
dans les 300 dollars
l'inde s'est monté à vélo pour la
première fois en même temps que nous
tous et on l'a vu partir à fond de train
c'est d'ailleurs la dernière chose qu'on
l'ait vu faire puisque depuis il n'a
plus jamais quitté la selle d'un vélo
l'inde ce passe son temps à parcourir
les rues de la ville et en 1980 lorsque
les amstrong des ménages vers plano une
banlieue de dallas c'est encore à vélo
qu'il explore son nouvel environnement
l'oms se sent de plus en plus à l'aise
sur deux roues il a du mal à trouver sa
place dans cette commune de plano la
plupart des familles ils sont plus
riches que la sienne il se voit ici
comme un étranger et ne digère pas la
chose il commence à s'accrocher
physiquement avec les jeunes du coin
son adaptation à notre nouvelle commune
a été assez difficile bien sûr il
gardait tout le loisir d'utiliser son
vélo pour se rendre à l'école
mais le jour de la rentrée je me
souviens que lorsqu'il est revenu à la
maison il s'était déjà battu avec un
garçon le fait qu'il ne soit pas doué
pour le foot ne l'êtes pas beaucoup non
plus même dans le reste du texas
plano est une commune qui vit
littéralement pour le football les
rencontres du vendredi sont en quelque
sorte le point culminant de la semaine
non seulement lentz a du mal à s'adapter
en classe mais l'atmosphère se dégrade à
la maison il ne supporte pas la façon
dont son beau père traite sa mère
il voyait bien que je n'étais pas
heureuse qu'on ne me respectaient pas
leurs s'essayer de me protéger
il a naturellement fini par perdre tout
respect envers cet homme qui malmenait
sa maman tous la colère en à gazinet à
cette époque a directement alimenté plus
tard son esprit de compétition
le premier sport de compétition pour
lequel lines découvre qu'il est doué et
la course à pied en cm2 ils visent la
victoire aux tests d'endurance de son
école il est revenu à la maison en me
disant je vais la gagner cette course et
je suis certaine qu au fond de lui
c'était aussi une manière de se dire je
vais leur montrer qui je suis à sega le
garçon le plus rapide de l'école se
nomme chamakh ray lane ce décide de le
battre tous les copains lui disait hey
tu ferais mieux de faire gaffe à tchane
landes cela répondait vous allez voir
qu'elle plus rapide et comment je vais
lui botter le cul et promesses tenues
landes se gagne la course
une discipline qui semble d'ailleurs
s'accorder aussi bien avec son physique
sec et nerveux qu'avec son tempérament
volcanique
dès lors il rejoint l'équipe de cross de
l'école dont il devient l'un des favoris
très apprécié
sur la lancée de son succès il décide de
s'essayer à un autre sport d'endurance
à 12 ans il se met à la natation c'est
même pas nager
ils tentent d'accéder directement à
l'équipe de natation de son centre de
loisirs municipal le voir sauter dans le
bassin et se démener pour réussir à
parcourir ces 100 m était quelque chose
qui me faisait monter les larmes aux
yeux il était fermement déterminé à
rejoindre l'équipe ailier arriver même
si je dois avouer qu'il s'est retrouvé
avec des ce2 beaucoup plus jeune que lui
vient l'idée étant de coeur qu'au bout
de deux mois il était devenu un très bon
nageur
en à peine un an
lentz se place 4e du texas au 1500 m
nage libre
à 13 ans il est une étoile montante de
la course et de la natation sont fidèles
vélo continue néanmoins de l'accompagner
sur ses nombreux trajets entre les deux
disciplines la même année là nous
apprend qu'un sport le triathlon combine
ces trois activités favorites
il s'y met évidemment et comment cela
aussi à se démarquer
en 1986 nouveau bouleversement à la
maison sa mère divorce lines demeure
bien entendu auprès d'elle
l'inde c'est linda se tenait deux ados
contre le reste du monde
il avait cette capacité à s'unir et à
faire face ensemble aux épreuves langue
c'était mon meilleur ami notre relation
s'est même davantage renforcée à cette
époque tous les soirs on se faisait une
joie de se retrouver pour dîner ensemble
et parler en détails de notre journée
linda est la plus fervente admiratrice
de lens
elle assiste à ces entraînements et
l'accompagnent dans ses rencontres
sportives à travers le texas
lens devient bientôt une véritable star
du triathlon son ami bart nax l'a vu
concourir à l'époque à waco juste au
moment où je prenais la tête de la
course
je vois ce petit punk de 15 ans des
boulets et me dépasser le plus
tranquillement du monde j'avais encore
10 km à parcourir lands a gagné la
course
il est monté sur le podium et a
simplement déclaré c'était sympa merci
je ne vous raconte pas la tête de la
sangle lanz acquiert rapidement une
double réputation celle d'un talentueux
triathlète et d'un jeune insolent qui se
vante de ses exploits
je me souviens de la réaction des
collègues au bureau qui regardait ses
premières interviews il disait c'est le
gamin le plus effrontés que j'ai jamais
vu moi je me contentais de sourires et
de leur répondre
vous savez c'est ça qui lui donne de
l'assurance pour gagner cette confiance
apparente est une façon de prouver son
existence
le triathlon devient l'exutoire de son
ressentiment
celui qui l'éprouvent contre un père
absent contre un beau père qu'il déteste
et contre des camarades qui l'ont
d'abord rejeté
[Musique]
il pouvait avoir la haine au point que
peu importe le gars qu'il avait devant
lui sa réputation ou sa position dans le
monde du sport il fallait qu'il le baril
en 1988 alors qu'il n'a que 16 ans l'oms
a déjà remporté des dizaines de
triathlon à travers le pays
il reçoit le titre de sportif de l'année
il se penche davantage sur le cyclisme
l'automne suivant
on invite à participer à une course
régionale au nouveau mexique
j'avais tellement peu d'expérience en la
matière qu'ils ne portaient même pas les
vêtements adaptés à ce type de
compétition
il faisait froid dehors il est sorti
s'échauffer sur son vélo et les rentrait
à son hôtel en grelottant linda a fini
par mettre la voiture en marche pour
chauffer l'habitacle avant que l'un
d'eux s'y engouffre à son arrivée l'inde
a bondi de la voiture vers son vélo il a
couru sa course en battant le record
les courses s'enchaînent ces victoires
finissent par le convaincre qu'il est
plus fait pour le cyclisme que pour tout
autre sport
je dirais qu'il s'agissait pour la nz de
devenir le meilleur
et lorsqu'il s'est aperçu qu'il était
devenu imbattable sur un vélo il a
arrêté son choix sur le cyclisme je
pense que j'étais destinée pour le vélo
la natation m'a amené vers le triathlon
il c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert le
vélo c'est curieux mais on pourrait
presque dire que je suis devenu site
liste parce que j'étais nageurs au
printemps 1989 avec le baccalauréat en
poche
lens est prêt à quitter plano pour
épouser une carrière de cycliste
c'est à l'automne juste après son 18e
anniversaire qu'il saisit sa première
chance avec une invitation à rejoindre
l'équipe de l' us national
linda vie cette décision avec amertume
en compagnie de lens
elle a tout fait pour que ce rêve
devienne réalité mais elle s'est quand
même temps elle perd là son fils et son
meilleur ami il fallait qu'il se trouve
un endroit où il pourrait en même temps
s'entraîner et devenir lui même en
menant sa propre vie il a pris cette
décision alors qu'il était encore jeune
et moi de mon côté j'avais la sensation
d'avoir tout simplement été amputée d'un
bras
lens en revanche s'attarde moins sur les
sentiments il veut absolument en
découdre avec les meilleurs cyclistes du
monde et lui tarde de savoir s'il en
sera capable début 1990 lance amstrong
à 18 ans il quitte son domicile de plano
au texas et intègre l'équipe de coureurs
de l' us national
son entraîneur chris carmichael pour
autant qu'ils apprécient les louanges
entendu sur le talent de lens n'en est
pas moins inquiet sur certains aspects
de sa personnalité
j'étais très impatient de faire sa
connaissance
en même temps il avait la réputation
d'être un jeune sportif effrontée et
particulièrement têtu pour leur première
compétition ensemble au japon carmichael
donne à son équipe l'instruction de
démarrer tranquillement la course en
ménageant ses efforts juste après le
premier tour
l'homme a eu l'idée de génie de
s'échapper d'un seul coup pour prendre
trente ou quarante secondes d'avancé sur
un groupe de 150 à 200 coureurs
vous imaginez son coach le regarde avec
des yeux ronds du genre mais qu'est ce
que tu fais landes ce qui lui passe
devant avec la banane en levant les
doigts du style tu as vu un peu comment
je me débrouille learned finira onzième
de la course et premier de son équipe 1
débuts honorables pour le jeune
américain
mais avec la mention peut mieux faire je
suis partagé entre deux sentiments
d'un côté je lui aurais bien donner une
bonne claque sur la nuque en lui disant
c'est un bon gars si tu respectes est un
tout petit peu les consignes on se
serait placée bien mieux que ça mais ce
qui m'a empêché de réagir de cette
manière
c'était tout à coup ce sentiment
extraordinaire d'être en présence d'un
athlète tout à fait unique
les 18 mois qui suivent lens les cours
sous la direction de carmichael lens à
l'endurance et la puissance nécessaire
pour se démarquer dans le monde du
cyclisme
les médecins reconnaissent que ses
aptitudes physiques sont en phase avec
une discipline aussi épuisante que le
cyclisme il a des talents de sportif
pratiquement surnaturel il est capable
d'utiliser son oxygène de manière
autrement plus efficace que n'importe
qui ne le ferait il restera sur son vélo
plus longtemps et dans les conditions
beaucoup plus rude que n'importe qui sa
capacité physique à supporter la douleur
est supérieure à celle de pratiquement
n'importe qui comme un cole devra donc
se contenter de le discipliner
je dirais que crise car michael s'est
attaché à remettre un peu de cervelle ou
bien disons d'esprit cyclisme dans ce
corps exceptionnel dès 1992
armstrong qui à 20 ans est une force
avec laquelle il faut compter dans le
monde du cyclisme amateur aux jeux
olympiques de barcelone
il fait figure de favori
malheureusement il ne termine que 14e
dans la course sur route on sa plus
grande déception c'est cependant dans
cette même ville qu'il retient
l'attention de jim o cowitz chef de
l'équipe motorola
celui ci propose à l'endss de les
rejoindre
je pense que jim locaux vides ça tout
simplement saisi tout ce que le monde
avait constaté chez amstrong un physique
de cyclistes absolument magnifique
doublé d'une profonde volonté
quelques semaines plus tard landes
secours pour la première fois en tant
que professionnel
c'est un jour de pluie froide en espagne
et l'homme se retrouve rapidement en
queue de peloton
il termine dernier
il n'a pas abandonné ses coéquipiers ont
dû se dire qu'ils étaient cinglés
quand il a passé la ligne d'arrivée ont
démonté le podium vous imaginez s'ils
étaient loin derrière cet échec est un
désastre pour lens
il poursuit néanmoins la compétition et
remonte peu à peu dans le peloton mais
il doit encore en apprendre beaucoup
n'avaient pas la moindre culture du
cyclisme à leurs yeux c'était plus un
quelconque sportif américain qui avait
débarqué là dedans qui était doué d'une
rare impertinence il avait son majeur
est aussi une langue bien pendue il n'a
pas hésité à s'en servir dans le monde
du cyclisme
les cyclistes européens ne savent pas
comment prendre ce jeune américain fort
en gueule
son style n'est pas pour leur plaire
même s'ils reconnaissent que c'est un
vainqueur en puissance
[Musique]
il ne s'est pas fait que des amis
seulement au delà de son impertinence il
était capable de créer du sens grâce à
la force de ses jambes et c'est
finalement ce qui nous impressionnait le
plus il n'avait qu'à le voir en selle
pour que ça leur fiche la trouille
en juin 1993 alors qu'il n'a encore que
21 ans lance remporte le championnat des
etats-unis après la dernière d'une
longue série d'ascension
[Musique]
lens devait avoir six coureurs qui le
collège il les a tout simplement scotché
sur place pour prendre quelque chose
comme 15 secondes d'avancé sur 800 m
c'était incroyable
c'est sous son maillot de champion des
états unis que l'on ne se remporte le 11
juillet 1993 sa toute première étape du
tour de france à verdun
s'il est contraint de se retirer de la
compétition après seulement douze jours
de course il se promet de revenir
[Musique]
lens s'est fixé un nouvel objectif
devenir champion du monde
il demande à sa mère de la compagne à
oslo en norvège
sept heures durant linda reste rivé sur
son fils coller au devant du peloton
l'inde sur la fin décide tout à coup une
fois de plus de s'envoler
j'ai vu à ce moment là toute la
détermination qu'il pouvait y avoir dans
son regard et je me suis dit ça y est
c'est parti et au dernier tour dans le
dernier virage il a mille mots terre
c'est l'un des coureurs les plus jeunes
est le premier américain depuis greg
lemon à devenir champion du monde
après la course on est venu prévenir
lorsque le roi de norvège souhaitait le
voir l'homme sont a été ravie et il a
demandé à sa mère de la compagnie là
elle lui répondu c'est à toi d'y aller
landes s'est tourné vers elle en
rétorquant non je ne suis pas du genre à
faire attendre ma mère à la sortie et
voilà comment nous avons été présentés
tous les deux au roi un an après être
arrivé dernier de sa toute première
course lance amstrong devient ainsi
champion du monde
1993 est une année extraordinaire il a
remporté trois courses majeures
essentiellement professionnel
normalement ces victoires se font durant
toute une carrière
mais lens lui les a enchaîné en l'espace
de quatre mois en europe
son titre de champion du monde l'a
propulsé du jour au lendemain ou devant
de la scène mais si ce championnat ne
lui vaut pas la même notoriété aux états
unis il a le mérite de lui offrir
quelque chose de bien plus important à
ses yeux l'argent landes se signe en
effet à nouveau et juteux contrat avec
motorola l'argent représente tout pour
lens
à un moment ça a même été la seule
magistral motivations de sa vie il lui
fallait s'acheter toutes ces choses avec
lesquelles ils avaient vu les autres
gamins jouer et auquel il n'avait pas eu
droit
lens commence par se faire construire
une nouvelle résidence au texas pas à
plano dont il s'est toujours sentie
exclue mais à austin où cuisiner bières
mexicaines sont loin de lui déplaire
vous êtes tous prêts pour la course et
c'est parti lance est un américain et sa
course préférée reste le tour du pont
une compétition par étape qui traverse
le sud est des états unis
il lui restait à prouver à tous les
américains qu'il était le meilleur
coureur il a choisi de le faire à
travers cette course hautement
symbolique à deux reprises landes se
place second autour du pont avant de le
remporter en 1995 son triomphe est
phénoménal mais à 23 ans il se souvient
qu'il n'a toujours pas achevé la plus
longue et la plus difficile de toutes
les courses par étapes le tour de france
dans le cyclisme européen il existe un
dicton qui dit que tant que vous n'avez
pas achevé votre tour de france vous
n'êtes pas un véritable professionnel
lance parcours la totalité du tour en
1995 mais une tragédie vient gâcher ses
chances de l'emporter
l'un de ses coéquipiers fabio casartelli
se tue dans une descente de pyrénées
je dirais que cet événement a marqué la
dernière phase de son éducation d'hommes
mais aussi de cyclistes quand fabio
s'est tué l'homme se réaliser comme me
l'a dit lui même que le tour de france
n'était pas une histoire de compétition
mais une histoire de vie et en
l'occurrence ici de mort
ce même jour de 1995 lance armstrong ne
sait pas encore que lui même devra
bientôt combattre pour sa propre ville
[Musique]
en 1996 lance armstrong est au sommet de
sa carrière de coureur au printemps
après sa victoire à cinq des douze
étapes du tour du pont
il demeure à battable 696 il était
parvenu un niveau hautement plus élevé
que quiconque et personne ne pouvait se
mesurer à lui dans cette course
en juillet 1996
l'oms est prêt à se lancer tête baissée
dans le tour de france
il espère cette fois se placer en tête
de peloton mais après seulement cinq
jours de compétition des problèmes de
respiration le force à abandonner
ils rentrent à hostile et s'entraîne
avec acharnement pour les jeux
olympiques d'atlanta après sa déception
de barcelone il veut faire de cette
année celle de sa médaille d'or de son
grand triomphe chez lui face à les fous
de compatriotes il a attaqué comme on
s'y attendait mais il n'a pas pu fournir
d'effort prolongé et par conséquent il
n'a pas gagné
bien que ce soit un cuisant échec landes
se conservent néanmoins de quoi se
réjouir
la nouvelle équipe cycliste française de
cofidis la vie à la rejoindre il
s'apprêtait à gagner un million de
dollars par an ce qui est énorme pour un
gosse qui est né à plano au texas
mais lens ne se sent pas bien
au cours de son 25e anniversaire en
septembre de violents maux de tête
l'obligent à quitter d'urgence le
concert auquel il assiste bien que
d'autres symptômes et commencer à le
harceler
il préfère ne pas en parler jusqu'à ce
mercredi 2 octobre où ils s'obligent à
blaise docteur qui a fini par le pouce
et j'ai son docteur c'est lorsqu'elle
s'est mis à vomir du sang dans le lavabo
c'est douleur était telle qu'il ne
pouvait plus s'asseoir ni sur un
fauteuil ni sur la selle de son vélo il
avait les testicules si gonflé que ce
jour là il lui a fallu pédaler debout
son médecin traitant l'envoi
immédiatement consulter un spécialiste
à l'autre bout de la ville après une
série d' analyse ce dernier reconvoque
lance à son cabinet il n'a pas perdu un
instant il a commencé par me montrer la
radio de ma poitrine où l'on voyait
plein de petites taches blanches et il
m'a déclaré comme ça vous avez un cancer
des testicules
je ne comprenais pas pourquoi il me
montrait la radio de montard axes le
cancer c'est tout simplement étendu à
ses poumons
pas moins de douze tumeur chacune de la
taille d'une balle de golf
s'il a d'abord réagi à ce diagnostic
comme si leur effet typiquement avec
toute forme de contraintes s'imposant à
lui c'est à dire par la colère
ses premiers mots en été j 24 ans
pourquoi donc est ce que j'aurai le
cancer sa réaction suivante a été de
dire ok on va l'anéantir dès le
lendemain matin 3 octobre
l'un d'eux subi l'ablation du testicule
cancéreux
l'intervention est un succès deux jours
plus tard il se rend auprès d'une banque
du sperme à san antonio les médecins
l'ont en effet informé que la
chimiothérapie le rendre et stérile
pendant au moins quelques années le
lundi 7 octobre lines suit sa première
séance de chimiothérapie avant
d'annoncer publiquement dès le lendemain
sa maladie jeudi 3 octobre j'ai subi à
l'hôpital saint david d'une intervention
chirurgicale visant à enlever un
testicule atteints de tumeurs malignes
l'opération a réussi
une scanographie pratiquer le jour même
a révélé que la maladie s'est étendue
dans mon abdomen malheureusement la
nhtsa n'en a pas fini avec les mauvaises
nouvelles
cette même semaine il apprend que le
cancer a également touché son cerveau
si un cancer des testicules est une
maladie en général très facilement
soignable l'état de lens grave au point
que les médecins croit difficilement à
sa guérison
en clair il avait moins de 50% de
chances de survivre
vu la répartition dans son corps des
tumeurs mais lens reste déterminée à
leur prouver le contraire
il s'envole vers indianapolis les
chercheurs de l'université de l'indiana
ont en effet été les premiers à
développer un traitement efficace contre
le cancer testiculaire il commence par
recommandé que l'on modifie une partie
de son traitement
on a estimé qu'il était important avant
tout d'enlever les deux zones du cerveau
qui avait été atteinte et ensuite on a
demandé à ce que sa chimiothérapie soit
modifié pour des médicaments tout aussi
efficace mais avec l'espoir qu'ils
seraient moins toxiques pour ces points
je les revois ce penchant tranquillement
en arrière sur leurs chaises et
m'annonçant comme ça vous savez on est
confiant on a déjà eu des patients dans
la même situation claveau pour les
aguerris ainsi le jeudi 24 octobre 1996
soit trois semaines après le premier
diagnostic lance retourne à l'hôpital
cette fois pour une intervention au
cerveau le chirurgien parvient à enlever
toutes les tumeurs
commence alors une course contre la
montre pour la vie de l'homme
il lui faudra encore affronter trois
séries de séances de chimiothérapie est
une chimiothérapie
c'est la guerre ni plus ni moins vous
comprenez cette saleté via l'intérieur
de vous laisser de vous tuer
j'ai eu la trouille je me suis dit que
j'irai peut-être à son enterrement dans
un futur pas si lointain
par contre on est vrai que lorsqu ils
éviteront via près de lui
vous aviez du mal à croire un tel état
de santé je ne pense pas qu'ils étaient
prêts à croire à sa propre mort ni même
qu'il aurait laissé d'autres personnes
envisagée pour entretenir sa motivation
et celle de ses amis
lantz continue notamment de courir
pendant son traitement en décembre ça ne
manquerait le retrouve alors qu'il vient
de subir une troisième série de séances
de chimiothérapie
il m'a dit la prochaine fois en même
temps vélo avec toi et moi je lui ai dit
quoi tu as un cancer tue suis une chimio
et lui ai alors lens devait penser que
s'il continuait de monter à vélo c'est
qu'il n'était pas si malade que ça et en
même temps ça renvoyait ses amis à
l'image que si l'inde se courait c'est
que ça allait plutôt bien
malheureusement les semaines qui suivent
voient se déclencher les pires effets
secondaires du traitement lands
s'écroule au cours d'un entraînement il
ne s'est pas arrêtée un seul instant de
rouler jusqu'à ce qu'il se retrouve
étendu dans un champ avec la sensation
affreuse qu'il allait peut-être y rester
le 13 décembre 1996
lens entame ses dernières séances de
chimiothérapie les médicaments ont
attaqué ses muscles et le traitement
anti nausées les puise alors qu'il est
encore hospitalisé un représentant de
l'équipe cofidis débarque de france
c'était une sale journée
j'étais vraiment au plus bas le
traversait l'une des phases les plus
épouvantables de la maladie et du
traitement
je me disais qu'il devait me considérer
comme faisant déjà partie de l'histoire
on lui confirme qu'il restera dans
l'écurie mais seulement pour une
fraction du million de dollars
initialement prévus on a renoncé à
croire en lui d'un coup comme ça en
plein milieu de sa thérapie
quelques jours plus tard la nouvelle
tant attendue tombe
le traitement a marché
son cancer est en rémission là on se
passe les fêtes de noël avec le
sentiment de revivre lentement mais
sûrement
pour cette soirée je me suis demandée
avec ou sans chapeau lens est passé à
deux doigts de la mort mais il remonte
la pente et me faut à présent continuer
de reconquérir salut c'est un fait
début 1997 lens a bel et bien remporté
son combat contre le cancer
le pronostic de spécialistes est
favorable mais à 25 ans il ne sait pas
s'il pourra continuer à courir en même
temps qu'il reprend du poil de la bête
l'un d'eux crée une fondation destinée à
financer la recherche et à aider les
malades du cancer
il recueille les fonds de cette oeuvre
en organisant une course caritative
christine ricciardo qui travaillait
alors pour l'un des sponsors présents
rencontre lens pour la première fois
lors d'une conférence de presse
annonçant l'événement lens venait tout
juste de terminer sa chimio
il était pâle et ne parlait pas beaucoup
il est évident qu'il ne pouvait pas se
sentir complètement à l'aise dans une
conférence de presse
et pourtant il s'est montré tout ce
qu'il ya de plus charmant et naturel je
n'oublierai jamais quand il est monté
sur le podium
j'ai vu un grand sourire illuminait son
visage et là je me suis dit à l'anz et
christin travaille à l'organisation de
la compétition
ils passent de plus en plus de temps
ensemble si elle est comme landes
d'un tempérament vif de nature aussi à
le mettre au défi à lui montrer les
choses sous un angle différent
en mars 1997 2000 personnes se
rassemblent pour assister à leurs
courses des roses
cette manifestation leur rapporte plus
de 200 mille dollars alors que plus rien
ne les retient à l'issue de leur
collaboration landes et christine
choisissent pourtant de continuer à se
voir
ils ont commencé à se trouver de bonnes
excuses pour se revoir et s'appelait et
peu un peu c'est devenu une belle
histoire d'amour
cependant l'avenir professionnel de la
landsdomur incertain cofidis a résilié
son contrat
et lorsqu'elle était 1997 il annonce
qu'il cherche une nouvelle écurie
personne ne vient se rencontrent se voir
rejeter par les européens a été une
chose très dur pour lui parce qu'il
pensait logiquement qu'il avait été
champion du monde qu'il avait remporté
des courses et des étapes dans le tour
de france
le fait que tout le monde l'ignorent le
sidérait totalement il était persuadé
d'être resté une bonne affaire alors
qu'en réalité les gens s'étaient
totalement désintéressé de lui
heureusement à l'automne 1997 l'équipe
américaine de l'us postal service lui
offre une place
il ne pouvait pas le pays énormément
mais ils ont mis au point un système de
primes
tout en restant confiants sur ses
performances
[Musique]
lens demande christine en mariage tous
deux s'expatrient vers l'europe début
1998 où lens reprend la compétition
at il retrouvé l'ensemble de ses
qualités exceptionnelles
tout le monde semble l'attendre au
tournant quel est il réellement
récupérer on pénétrait là en terrain
inconnu où tout ne pouvait être que pure
théorie il m'avait dit qu'avec seulement
2 à 3 % de capacité en moins il ne
faudrait plus espérer de miracles de sa
part et j'ai pensé que ce serait
peut-être malheureusement le cas en
février 1998 l'orne ce participant en
espagne à la ruta del sol et se place
15e
trois semaines plus tard il s'élance sur
le paris nice
au cours de la première étape affaibli
par de mauvaises conditions météo
il abandonne il a dit comme ça j'en ai
marre de tout ça et les gens ont cru que
c'était certainement la dernière fois
qu'ils le voyaient en tant que
professionnel ses amis le convainquent
de s'accorder encore au moins une course
en avril 1998
chris carmichael l'emmène s'entraîner à
beaune en caroline du nord précisément
là où il avait participé autour du pont
il connaissait ses routes par coeur il
en avait été le héros et je me suis dit
que ce serait une bonne chose que de le
replonger dans ce type de souvenirs
ce voyage avec d'anciens encouragement à
sa gloire
retrouvez pas sur l'asphalté des routes
déclenchant lui un véritable déclic
avant de repartir pour l'europe landes
et christine se maria santa barbara le 8
mai 1998 lens se replonge corps et âme
dans la compétition et revient à son
plus haut niveau
il enchaîne deux victoires l'une retour
du luxembourg l'autre à celui de
rhénanie palatinat et ce n'est pas fini
tout le monde trouvait ça incroyable
quatrième au tour de hollande quatrième
au tour d'espagne quatrième un
championnat du monde
si c'est pas ce qu'on appelle un
come-back la fin de la saison prouve que
c'est effectivement un come back
sur sa lancée et sur les encouragements
du belge johan bruyneel
le nouveau directeur de l' us postal
lance vise à nouveau le plus haut titre
qui soit celui de champion du tour de
france pour nous américains ce n'est pas
seulement qu'une course de trois
semaines
c'est une course où il faut être au top
de sa forme tous les jours pour lui
c'était à la fois un bouleversement et
un risque lourd à courir mais lente
c'était en même temps et nomme nouveau
capable de prouver qu'il pouvait encore
surprendre sur beaucoup de choses
avant de repartir pour la france le
couple armstrong veut un enfant
christine subi une fécondation in vitro
avec le sperme de lens conserver avant
la chimiothérapie
en février 1999 la fécondation a marché
christine est enceinte
c'est un couple heureux qui s'envole
pour l'europe il s'établit à nice où
lens fait des montagnes voisines son
lieu d'entraînement intensif il
ressentait une nouvelle motivation
auparavant il lui arrivait de temps en
temps d'oublier l'entraînement mais là
on avait l'impression qu'il chérissait
chaque jour de sa vie
le tour dure trois semaines et la
préparation de l'homme avait duré de six
à huit mois
il a véritablement bâti pierre par
pierre son tour de france avec la plus
grande détermination de la patience en
plus lorsque le monde du cyclisme évoque
alors lancé sur un ton quelque peu
péjoratif on parle d'un rescapé du
cancer s'évertuant à vouloir remporter
une course qui lui a toujours échappé
personne ne me voyait gagner
personne n'aurait jamais parié sur ma
victoire dans ce tour de france
personne ne me voyait lorsque le 3
juillet 1999 il remporte la première
étape du tour tout le monde est
abasourdi
le voilà endossant à présent le fameux
maillot jaune
le tout premier jour je me voyais
remporté les préliminaires du tour vous
imaginez la joie
le rêve était devenu réalité cela a
provoqué un choc
inimaginable vous aviez la survivants du
cancer qui avait réussi à reconquérir sa
réputation de pointures mondiales mais
sans que quiconque ne s'attendent à ce
qu'ils prétendent réellement au tour de
france
et là tout à coup le voilà qui remporte
la première étape
au neuvième jour de l'événement landes
se démarque à nouveau cette fois dans
l'une des ascensions les plus pénibles
du parcours et remporte l'étape
tout porte à croire qu'il ait mis le cap
sur la victoire les médias américains
jubile et débarque pour couvrir
l'actualité de la plus grande
manifestation de toute l'histoire du
sport
l'europe pour sa part reste encore
incrédule sur les derniers exploits de
l'oms
on m'a demandé comment il était possible
que quelqu'un parvenu à l'article de la
mort remonte la pente et remporte
l'épreuve sportive la plus difficile du
monde
on l'a fait de manière agressive l'année
précédente la révélation du dopage de
plusieurs coureurs avaient entaché la
réputation du tour les accusations de la
presse se portent désormais sur nos
routes
ces supputations le révoltent ils
répondent en redoublant d'obstination
dans ses efforts
cela a été pour la presse l'occasion
rêvée de jeter le discrédit sur lui et
d'essayer de le briser
mais ils ne sont pas parus et envie de
dire que la seule manière d'être certain
qu'il gagne une course c'est justement
de montrer qu on le rejette le rejeter
ces provoqué au contraire toute sa
motivation
l'oms a pris la tête du tour pour ne
plus la quitter
le 25 juillet ils revendiquent la
victoire ses amis et sa famille ont pris
place le long des champs-elysées pour
vivre ses derniers tours avant la ligne
d'arrivée
on s'est mis à hurler à crier et tant
pis si ça faisait un peu désordre
c'était pour nous un moment d'une force
comme on a du mal à l'imaginer
cette victoire extraordinaire
concrétiser récompense les immenses
efforts de relance ils insistent pour
que partout dans le monde elle soit
aussi la victoire des cancéreux sur leur
maladie
je savais que j'allais délivrer un
message à une personne à une autre
quelqu'un allait forcément puiser dans
cet exploit de l'inspiration de l'espoir
ce pouvait être une seule personne comme
dissous ou même un million ainsi le
regard de lance amstrong descendant les
champs elysées devient-il symbole
d'espoir pour les personnes atteintes
d'un cancer
surprise de taille l'attend en retour
l'accueil qu'on lui réserve aux états
unis après sa victoire du tour de france
1999 lance amstrong reçoit son retour
aux états unis un accueil au delà de
tout ce qu'il aurait pu imaginer
je n'ai jamais vu une chose pareille
c'était une liesse populaire digne du
retour d'un astronaute depuis la lune ou
quelque chose de ce genre
les gens étaient littéralement fous de
joie et moi avec l'histoire de l'oms a
touché une corde sensible
si les américains n'avaient jusque là
jamais prêté grande attention au
cyclisme il rattrape à présent le temps
perdu
lantz devient la coqueluche de la nation
on le célèbre de la bourse de new york à
la maison blanche en passant par sa
ville d'austin où a lieu une grande
parade un pur bouleversements dans sa
vie et celle de christine il est devenu
tout à kohat héros national et
international vous savez ça métamorphosé
leur vie à l'automne ils célèbrent une
autre victoire autrement plus intime le
12 octobre 1999 n'est leur fils luc
david
son nouveau rôle de père transporte
lance de joie je pense qu'il a saisi
cette chance comme celle de fonder de
foyers auxquels ils n'avaient jamais eu
droit de venir un peu le père qu'il n'a
pas vu c'est quelque part une façon de
revenir en arrière et de réécrire les
choses
[Musique]
il vit un enchantement total sa femme et
son fils le comble comme aucune course
ne le fera jamais à l'automne 1999
landes s'attelle à un autre projet qui
lui tient à coeur
il écrit en compagnie de salies jenkins
son autobiographie leur livre intitulé
en france il n'y a pas que le vélo de la
vie devient un best-seller le visage de
l'homme est désormais partout il s'est
entouré de nouveaux sponsors tourner
dans des publicités
l'une d'entre elles pour la marque nike
est une réponse à ce qu'il avait vu
en 2000 ces salaires et autres
venu lui rapporte plus de 7 millions de
dollars mélanz autrefois très attiré par
l'argent à d'ores et déjà d'autres
priorités l'argent était pour lui
synonyme de succès c'était une façon de
mesurer à quelle distance il avait été
capable de s'éloigner de sa petite
banlieue de plano il s'agissait avant
tout pour lui de marquer des points
au printemps 2000 la famille armstrong
est de retour sur la côte d'azur
lens veut en effet participer au
prochain tour de france
ses détracteurs avancent qu en 1999
lantz n'avait pas encore affronter la
crème des coureurs il pourrait cette
fois ne pas être à la hauteur de ses
prétentions
on lui a dit comme ça c'est vrai tu as
remporté une belle victoire mais il
suffit que tu te retrouves face à jan
ullrich ou un marco pantani en bonne
condition physique et tu verras tu feras
pas le poids
six mois avant que ne débute la course
il m'a dit je vais la gagner cette
course
personne ne m'en crois capable ils vont
voir justement l'homme ce ménage ses
efforts en début de course
il faut attendre le 10 juillet soit 10
jours après le début de la compétition
pour le voir s'élancer une fois de plus
sur les parcours montagneux
il a démarré en trombe et le groupe qui
l'accompagné n'en a pas cru ses yeux de
voir à quelle vitesse il s'est mis à
pédaler il dépassait les 100 tours de
roue par minute son rythme là on se
tient jusqu'à paris il remporte une
seconde fois le tour pour la plus grande
fierté de ses compatriotes présents
une victoire qu'il savoure encore plus
que la précédente plus un instant
extrêmement privilégié pour landis est
de pouvoir le partager comme ça avec son
fils c'était un accomplissement
merveilleux lands s'envole ensuite pour
participer aux jeux olympiques de sydney
il tente pour la troisième fois la
médaille d'or et la manque de peu en
empochant une médaille de bronze au
contre la montre
[Musique]
tu penses que ce jour-là à sydney j'ai
été la plus fière parce qu'il s'en est
tiré avec la plus grande classe qui soit
vous ne pouvez pas toujours avoir tout
dans la vie
je crois que la différence se juge dans
l'art et la manière d'encaisser cette
réalité c'est justement ce qui fait un
homme
et si vous saviez combien je l'aimais ce
jour là le 2 octobre 2002 jours après la
victoire de cette médaille
l'inde se célèbre le quatrième
anniversaire de son diagnostic du cancer
le 2 octobre
c'est notre grande fête de famille est
un peu comme un deuxième anniversaire
pour l'un c'est le jour où l'on célèbre
tout simplement le fait qu'ils soient en
vie
une victoire sur le cancer dont il a
conscience qu'elle est chargée de sens
il devait faire un choix entre remporté
le tour est surmontée à nouveau un
cancer il repartirait aussi sec dans la
lutte contre la maladie
parce que d'un côté on a réellement une
expérience de foi d'ordre mystique et de
l'autre on a juste une course de vélo
pour lui ce n'est donc pas une question
de choix je préfère qu'on parle de moi
comme un survivant du cancer
c'est ce que j'ai réalisé deux nuls
en suivant la carrière de lance
armstrong on ne peut que s'émerveiller
face à ce gamin de plano au texas qui
s'est hissé parmi les plus grands noms
du cyclisme européen tout en poursuivant
son propre parcours du combattant tout
le monde aux états unis adorent les
histoires de come back
tout le monde adore quand l'un de nos
gars sort du lot et se démarque par
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
parvenir au sommet de sa condition
physique après avoir vaincu une maladie
grave au point de remporter deux fois un
tour de france c'est la plus belle
démonstration d'endurance qui soit
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est passé à deux doigts
de la mort et quand je vois ce qu'il est
parvenu à faire on a vraiment là ce
qu'un être humain peut produire de
meilleurs lens est un modèle d'espoir
d'inspiration aussi et ça c'est vraiment
l'essentiel